but I'm Michael soon
so back here again mm-hmm how is it
different doing stand-up as opposed to
doing it in front of a live audience
with SNL like how does it different that
experience because live audience
stand-up is the live audience I think
the difference is in language and
different words you can't say in the
time the time restrictions but for the
most was the same people of people like
what are you get rid of being in front
of a live audience when you're telling
jokes I it feeds my ego and then I go
outside and I can't get a cab it's just
fun it's fun is there's nothing like
seeing people laugh yeah yeah so that's
not weren't hiatus right now when it was
last summer you guys did the summer
shows right the weekend update' summer
shows is that last summer oh yeah so
let's still feel it like is it killing
you a little bit like we're some of the
things that are happening that you can't
know it's not killing me at all it's
actually pleasant it's actually pretty
fun to not have to do it sometimes yeah
that's the thing like is it sometimes
hard to find the funny about some of the
things that are happening no it's not
hard to find funny is ends up being
exhausting faggins are funny sometimes
because you just want to talk about
different things and we're kind of in
this weird political cycle where it
seems like the same thing over and over
again so it's it's not as fun always so
these summer breaks are actually good
because then you're excited to go back
to work yeah something you kind of need
yes so that's not me for a bunch of
Emmys again yeah a bunch that's a record
yeah then you guys host it out there
it's not the most yes hosted last year
yes I'm so sorry about that
one less thing for the rumors they're
not even gonna have a host yeah we broke
[Applause]
honored to be the last anyhow I feel
like people should lead with that
ya know what do you think that just like
the Oscars didn't have a whole sake do
you like that idea that award shows I'm
going for that host honestly I do like
it I think that well even as a host you
you know that the night is for the
denominator right and so you're just
there to kind of entertaining me between
awards but for the most part people are
there to see the winners and people are
there to see losers crying I like to see
what rich people cry yes some people
want to see them win that's one too so
yeah I think I think they know what
they're doing Academy knows what they're
doing you know sorry
well I mean now you guys have a little
more free time you can say that's true
I'm planning a wedding that's right
right you're gonna have like any
suggestions for the wedding
yes I'm wearing white every great if I
show that we're in exactly what's Carlos
here sure it'll be fun and I'm really
really proud of those guys and I'm sure
that they'll have beautiful white babies
this year was Pete Davidson like coming
out and really talking about his
personal life like a lot of the time was
really different for what we see how it
was like that for you guys like him
addressing all these various things
spotting the CPB Pete I think like
that's kind of always cool to see Pete
just be Pete well I guess it's it's fun
yeah now lastly big fan we've got summer
summer summer summer slam Summer Slam
summer slim Stephan and Paul thank you
so much for having us we got a blast I
do not have any predictions and I go
back again oh my god yeah when I was
raised on WWE and and they'd am so
friggin professional and awesome and we
had a blast like we really really did
yeah it was so much fun they yeah
if you're at home and you want to become
a double W superstar I would highly
recommend it really is a lot of those
are through I felt tall most people are
like shorter than me but you're like
tall let's take away energy Blake
Griffin today's the first person I've
ever ever needed that was taller yeah
you should interview sports at mathletes
are you really sure
okay well the wrestler festival you too
man time off I'm here for another day
all right I'm gonna jump through this
window yeah it's hot I'm like burning up
and nervous yeah yes I'm stupid